[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
janna pareigis einen schönen guten abend
und herzlich willkommen was beim sport
heute liefer fahren sie von norbert
könig genannt die großen themen an
diesem tag
offener schlagabtausch im eu-parlament
polens ministerpräsident wirft der
eu-kommission im streit um
rechtsstaatlichkeit erpressung vor
dramatische corona lage in rumänien die
krankenhäuser sind total überlastet
andere länder schicken hilfsgüter
und ein paradies für leseratten nach
einem ja corona pause startet in
frankfurt wieder die internationale
buchmesse
es kommt nicht oft vor dass sich im eu
parlament so harte worte an den kopf
geworfen werden auf der einen seite
polens regierungschef moravetz g der
sich von der eu nicht in sachen
rechtsstaatlichkeit in seinem land
reinreden lassen will auf der anderen
die eu die nicht weniger auf dem spiel
stehen sieht als ihre gemeinsamen werte
gunnar krüger hier der ministerpräsident
von polen dort die präsidentin der eu
kommission
schlagabtausch auf europas bühne mit
ansage denn vor knapp zwei wochen
erklärten in warschau regierungstreue
richter wichtige artikel der eu verträge
seien nicht mit polens verfassung
vereinbar das trifft mitten ins mark der
rechtsstaatlichkeit das hat es so noch
nie gegeben und darüber diskutieren wir
doch die werkzeuge der kommission sind
stumpf ihre klage vorm ogh wird von
polen ignoriert im verfahren nach
artikel 7 könnte sie polen stimmrechte
entziehen doch den beschluss blockiert
ungarn der rechtsstaats mechanismus
greift nur bei missbrauch von eu geld so
bleibt der aufbau von den die kommission
nun sperrt was beim gast zumindest für
empörung sorgt dass keine eu politiker
die polen erpressen finanzielle
erpressung darf kein mittel der politik
sein sein argument die eu sei ein
bündnis freier staaten kein
zentralistisches gebilde ja aber
entgegnet des alten europa ist kein
staat
europa ist eine staatengemeinschaft aber
wir haben uns mit dieser
staatengemeinschaft verpflichtetet dass
wir eine hausordnung einhalten die
verfassung der mitgliedstaaten ist
fundamental aber die hausordnung dieser
gemeinschaft ist wichtiger herr morales
ski hören sie auf zu zünden das hier ist
kein spiel wie schlafwandeln richtung eu
austritt gegen den willen ihrer
europäischen freunde und gegen den
willen vor allem des polnischen volkes
ob die europäischen freunde den
mitbewohner murawski überzeugen nächste
chance übermorgen beim eu-gipfel in
brüssel
freunden also verhärtet gunnar krüger
wie wollen sich die eu und polen da
jetzt wieder annähern
matthäus bereits jetzt gerhard
tatsächlich heute eine gelegenheit zur
ernährung bravourös verstreichen lassen
er hat vor dem parlament gesprochen aber
er hat vor allem zu seinen wählern
gesprochen und denen hat er das bild
einer eu gemalt so wie es auch die ihm
treu ergebenen richter zeichnen nämlich
eine ein binnenmarkt eine art verteil
maschine die geld schickt aber keine
bedingungen stellt welche optionen hat
die eu nun darauf zu antworten das sind
zwei zum einen sie kann auch hart sein
sie kann mittel streichen oder zumindest
zurückhalten so wie es die abgeordneten
fordern so wie es auch die kommission
zumindest plant oder sie kann
verhandlungsbereit sich zeigen sie kann
reden so wie es die deutsche
bundeskanzlerin zuletzt übrigens in
belgien gefordert hat und das ist kein
zufall denn belgien ist eins der drei
länder nämlich die benelux länder
niederlande belgien und luxemburg das
sind die einzigen drei die bislang
fordern dass man polen die mittel kürzen
sollte alle anderen haben die sorge dass
polen zum blockierer werden könnte bei
anderen wichtigen themen wie zum
beispiel der dem umbau dem
klimafreundlichen umbau der europäischen
wirtschaft also der beide rollt nun von
straßburg nach brüssel war es übermorgen
eu-gipfel da ist wieder matthäus
morawski zu gast und es gibt wieder eine
gelegenheit zur annäherung da mal sehen
wie oft der ball hin und her rollt
vielen dank für diese einschätzung unter
krueger
nach deutschland am donnerstag sollen
die verhandlungen für eine
ampelkoalition beginnen gerade bei der
finanzierung der vorhaben der drei
parteien sind aber noch viele fragen
offen jetzt haben sich grünen-chefin
berbalk sowie der spd vorsitzende walter
borjans dafür ausgesprochen die
milliarden vorhaben teilweise auch über
kredite zu finanzieren
gleichzeitig soll die schuldenbremse
eingehalten werden so der plan
aufs geld achten müssen zurzeit viele in
deutschland wegen der steigenden preise
für sprit strom und gas die
preisexplosion bei treibstoffen stelle
eine massive belastung der wirtschaft da
die arbeitsplätze wachstum und wohlstand
gefährdet so der bundesverband
mittelständische wirtschaft erfordert
eine temporäre senkung der
mineralölsteuer und eine erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale
die deutsche wirtschaft leidet aber
nicht nur unter hohen energiepreisen ist
fehlt auch an rohstoffen aktuelles
problem ist der mangel an magnesium das
brauchen unter anderem auto und
stahlindustrie aber der wichtigste
exporteur von magnesium china hat seine
produktion drastisch reduziert für
deutsche firmen ein problem denn schon
ende november könnten die vorräte
europaweit aufgebraucht sein oliver
deuker mithin einzuleiten die firma
gedas 500 mitarbeiter in solcher
produzieren sie druckgussteile aus
aluminium und magnesium unter anderem
karosserie und motorteile für die
automobil- und flugzeugindustrie
seit januar hat sich der magnesium preis
mehr als verfünffacht mittlerweile ist
es schwer überhaupt noch magnesium zu
bekommen
denn magnesium nicht mehr vorhanden ist
dass auch die aluminiumlegierung nicht
mehr gefertigt werden können wir
brauchen magnesium als bestandteil
unserer produkte und im endeffekt können
wir dann nicht mehr produzieren 87
prozent der weltweiten enorme energie
verbrauchenden magnesium herstellung
besitzt china doch der strom ist derzeit
knapp im reich der mitte die energie
wird an anderer stelle gebraucht der
zeit wurde die magnesium produktion
massiv heruntergefahren
die winter kürzung
werden dieses jahr die situation im
übrigen auch nochmals verschärfen weil
die energie versorgung der bevölkerung
hat vorrang vor der versorgung der
industrie
deutschlandweit sind mehr als 250
betriebe mit rund 62.000 mitarbeiter
direkt von den magnesium importen
abhängig dabei bleibt es ja nicht
sondern wir haben diesen dominoeffekt in
die ganze lieferkette rein ja also in
die automobilindustrie flugzeugindustrie
die bauern verpackungsindustrie verbände
gewerkschaften und industrie haben nun
einen brandbrief an die bundesregierung
geschrieben darin fordern sie
diplomatische gespräche mit china um die
weiterführung der produktion in
deutschland gewährleisten zu können
2001 wurde die letzte magnesium
produktion in europa aus kostengründen
geschlossen alternativen zu chinesischen
importen sind derzeit weltweit kaum
vorhanden nicht nur bei der riders läuft
die zeit
der flughafen frankfurt hahn im hunsrück
hat insolvenz angemeldet
bis zu vier millionen passagiere pro
jahr zählte der regionalflughafen zu
hochzeiten vor allem dank der
billigfluglinie ryanair
aber die zahlen gehen seit jahren zurück
schon vor dem chor ohne
reisebeschränkungen nur das
frachtgeschäft stieg zuletzt weiter an
welche auswirkungen die insolvenz auf
die flüge haben wird ist noch unklar
viele ließ das sicher aufhorchen
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen weil
die korona notlage ende november
auslaufen lassen zustimmung von der
deutschen krankenhausgesellschaft
kritik von der deutschen stiftung
patientenschutz
es wäre gefährlich die epidemische lage
von nationaler tragweite zitat allein
aus fragwürdigem politischen kalkül
auslaufen zu lassen schauen wir wie die
korona lage zurzeit ist
keine besucher betreten verboten 60 und
76 bewohnern dieses pflegeheims in
norderstedt sind mit corona infiziert
fast alle sind geimpft fast alle haben
nur leichte symptome nur zwei senioren
müssen in die klinik der fall zeigt
impfung schützt aber corona ist noch
lange nicht besiegt aktuell liegen gut
zwei von 100.000 einwohnern mit kurve
dem krankenhaus der allergrößte teil
davon ungeimpft das personal im
dauerstress die belastung ist groß aber
wir sind noch weit von dem entfernt was
man eine komplette überlastung des
gesundheitssystems bezeichnen könnte wir
müssen auch immer gucken regional ist es
immer sehr unterschiedlich zurzeit sind
die instanzen im norden und westen
deutschlands relativ niedrig in
thüringen sachsen und bayern dagegen
eher kritisch da vor allem in den
grenzregionen
besonders betroffen sind aktuell die
kinder für sie gibt es noch keine
impfung die inzidenz der fünf bis 14
jährigen liegt bei 147 5 doch virologen
geben vorsichtig entwarnung
dadurch dass kinder zum glück ja
wirklich nur leicht krank werden und
schwere fälle sind die super super super
ausnahme glaube ich sollte uns das nicht
so viel gedanken machen ab ende november
wird nur noch die landesparlament über
corona maßnahmen entscheiden das heißt
vorbei ist die zeit der harten
bundesweiten verordnungen wie lockdown
veranstaltungs verbote kontakt
beschränkungen es bleiben aber die aha
regeln abstand handhygiene und masken in
innenräumen und zugangsbeschränkungen
mit zwei oder drei g khroma wird uns
wohl noch länger seine regeln diktieren
auch wenn die inzidenz in deutschland
wieder leicht steigt heute auf rund 75
in anderen europäischen ländern liegt
sie noch deutlich höher in rumänien zum
beispiel liegt die in zeiten tage
incidents aktuell bei
525 in den krankenhäusern gibt es keinen
freien platz mehr wolf christian ullrich
über das rumänische gesundheitssystem im
ausnahmezustand
in diesem krankenhaus in cluj gibt es
nicht mal mehr eine freie trage selbst
die notaufnahme ist durch corona
patienten blockiert die nicht mehr auf
die intensivstation passen die ärzte
sprechen von der schlimmsten situation
seit dem beginn der pandemie
die intensivstation ist seit wochen voll
wenn ein bett frei wird dann meistens
weil jemand gestorben ist unter den
schweren fällen auf der intensivstation
haben die allermeisten keine impfung
mitten in der aktuellen corona krise
zerbrach nun auch noch die regierung
entsprechend wenig autorität hatte
interimsregierungschef wenn er für die
impfung wird
wer nicht kämpft ist sollte das dringend
tun das ist jetzt die einzige lösung
nicht mal ein drittel der rumänischen
bevölkerung ist vollständig gegen korona
geimpft das misstrauen gegenüber der
regierung ist groß und
schauergeschichten im internet tun ihr
übriges
die autoritäten lügen uns doch an nehmen
sie mal ihre kamera und gehen sie zum
krankenhaus da ist alles leer ruft diese
frau
das krankenhaus ist aber nicht leer
sondern überfüllt mit corona patienten
die um ihr leben kämpfen
die impfkampagne sollte auch priester
und landärzte einsetzen die
glaubwürdigkeit in den dörfern und
kleinstädten haben
inzwischen helfen eu-staaten mit
medikamenten und sauerstoff maschinen
noch nie war die korona krise in
rumänien so dramatisch wie jetzt
es ist einer der letzten prozesse in
deutschland um mutmaßliche täterinnen
und täter des ns regimes zur
verantwortung zu ziehen beihilfe zum
mord in mehr als 11.000 fällen im ns
konzentrationslager stutthof wird einer
früheren sekretärin des kz vorgeworfen
irgendwas ist heute 96 jahre alt
überlebende des kz verfolgen das
verfahren und schildern unsere autorin
sarah tacke erlebt das leid im kz
stutthof
die schlimmste aller änderungen sind
natürlich die
zählappell
ich bin gestanden zwischen den beinen
von meiner mutter
und sie hat mich gewarnt ich habe sie
gewarnt
josef salomone witsch war ein kleiner
junge als die nazis ihn und seine
familie ins konzentrationslager stutthof
deportierten seinen vater und mehr als
65.000 menschen ermordeten die nazis
hier die listen mit den opfern soll
irmgard f abgetippt haben sie war die
sekretärin des lagerkommandanten ob sie
von den morden im lager wusste genau das
soll der prozess klären viele
kritisieren dass irgendwas elf jetzt 75
jahre nach ihrer mutmaßlichen tat
angeklagt wird der grund erst vor fünf
jahren 2016 entschied der
bundesgerichtshof dass auch gehilfen wie
werther oder anderes kz personal sich
wegen beihilfe schuldig gemacht haben
können als teil des organisierten
mordens im kz
nur durch dieses zusammenwirken wurde es
ermöglicht dass diese massentötung
überhaupt funktioniert haben und dann
kann man sagen auch ein vergleichsweise
kleiner beitrag wie eine sekretärin eine
stenotypistin die diktate aufgenommen
hat hat in dieser art und weise an
diesem gesamtsystem als rädchen im
getriebe eben mitgewirkt dem überleben
im salon monowitz ist der prozess ging
ihm geht es auch jetzt noch wichtig
deutschland braucht das und das ist gut
dass wir das marken bisschen zu spät ich
bin es 83 das erfahren auf das
überlebende so lange warten mussten es
soll jetzt klären was die justiz
jahrzehntelang nicht aufgearbeitet hat
seit jahrzehnten lockt frankfurt am main
im herbst immer menschen aus aller welt
zur buchmesse
sie ist die international größte
bücherschau im letzten jahr fand sie
wegen corona allerdings nur digital
statt aber ab heute heißt es wie connect
bekommen zurück in frankfurt annemie
bedingt kommen zwar weniger aussteller
und besucher und besucherinnen aber an
großen namen beispielsweise aus dem
gastland kanada und dann aktuellen
debatten fehlt es auch in diesem jahr
nicht markus wolsiffer
multikulturell modern bund so
präsentiert sich kanada im pavillon auf
der frankfurter buchmesse der ehrengast
will lust machen auf seine vielfältige
literatur und zur diskussion anregen wie
wollen wir leben das motto der
diesjährigen buchmesse und für direktor
jürgen boos eine der zentralen fragen
unserer zeit stellen uns diese frage
angesichts der alarmierenden ruhm des
umgangs miteinander
der unüberbrückbar scheinen spaltung
unserer gesellschaft
wir beobachten wie vehement und
lautstark partikularinteressen
vorgetragen werden die den blick auf
ziele vorstellen die aber nur gemeinsam
erreichen können
nach der fast komplett digitalen messe
2020 dürfen sich bücherfreunde aus aller
welt wie der physisch begegnen etwa 300
autorinnen und autoren werden in den
nächsten tagen nach frankfurt kommen ein
stück normalität und doch ist vieles
anders waren vor corinna noch etwa 7.500
aussteller dabei sind es diesmal nur
etwa 2000 und dennoch blickt die branche
optimistisch nach vorne die umsätze
seien wieder auf vor corinna niveau in
der krise hat sich gezeigt wie fest das
buch in der gesellschaft verankert ist
mit enormem engagement und viel
kreativität vor allem aber auch viel
erfolg haben buchhandlungen trotz
geschlossener ladentüren weiter bücher
verkauft ab freitag öffnet die buchmesse
für jedermann pro tag sind maximal
25.000 besucher erlaubt und rein darf
nur wer geimpft getestet oder genesen
ist
glück im unglück hatten die passagiere
eines regionalflugzeugs im us
bundesstaat texas aus noch ungeklärten
gründen konnte die maschine beim start
keine höhe gewinnen und schoss über die
rollbahn hinaus erst auf einem feld kam
sie zum stehen alle 21 menschen an bord
konnten sich in sicherheit bringen bevor
feuer ausbrach nur ein passagier wurde
verletzt
warum abend auftritt des fc bayern bei
benfica lissabon da steht hier ein
spieler besonders im fokus ein
abwehrspieler der vor einer ungewissen
zukunft steht denn lukas landes muss
möglicherweise demnächst eine
sechsmonatige haftstrafe antreten ein
anderes hatte vor vier jahren in spanien
einer handgreiflichen auseinandersetzung
mit seiner jetzigen ehefrau gegen ein
gerichtlich angeordnetes kontaktverbot
verstoßen dem vor zwei jahren für die
rekord summe von 80 millionen euro von
atlético madrid zu den bayern gewechselt
fernandez war heute im abschlusstraining
nichts anzumerken von einer drohenden
haftstrafe
die muss er am 28 oktober antreten falls
seine berufung vorher keinen erfolg hat
seinen trainer versetzt das noch nicht
in sorge
habe natürlich meine meinung dazu die
ich jetzt nicht kundtun was mich nichts
angeht ist an seine persönlichen themen
so lange auf dem platz vollgas geben
kann und es kann auch er ist ein
vollprofi hat lust zu gewinnen und
konzentrierte profi ist darf man sich
auch nicht erlauben bei benfica lissabon
hier in rot die schwächelnde mannschaft
des fc barcelona kam dort vor drei
wochen mit 0 zu 3 unter die räder
die bayern hatten mit demselben ergebnis
in barcelona gewonnen allein daran
gemessen könnte morgen ein duell auf
augenhöhe anstehen
platz acht in der bundesliga
tabellenletzte in der champions league
und hort dort heute abend eine kaum
lösbare aufgabe für trainer jesse
marsch- und rb leipzig im prinzenpark
stadion wartet paris st germain
um hier zu bestehen braucht man
selbstbewusstsein paris asamoah
souveräner tabellenführer in frankreichs
liga und mit dem starensemble um super g
und messi auch ohne den verletzten
nehmer eine herkulesaufgabe für rb
leipzig das ist ein super spielen im
super stadion diese mal mit mit fenster
bei lasst uns nach paris fliegen mit mit
total leidenschaft den surf vertrauen
vieles hängt auch davon ab ob leipzig
paris export christophen coco treffen
kann wie bislang viermal in der
bundesliga vier mal in der champions
league eine niederlage würde ein
weiterkommen in der königsklasse
jedenfalls extrem erschweren
um aber das motto du hast keine chance
also nutze sie
morgen ist der tag vor dem sturm und
wahrscheinlich der wärmste tag der
nächsten paar monate mehr dazu gleich
von katja hall war um 21 45 können sie
das heute journal sehen mit marietta
slomka auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
abend heute brachte diese warmfront
etwas regen morgen wird es sehr mild und
dann kommt ein sturmtief das entwickelt
sich aus dieser kaltfront heraus die
kräftigsten windböen gibt es in der
nacht zu donnerstag und donnerstag über
tag ist etwa donnerstagmittag im
flachland gibt es dann
windgeschwindigkeiten von 70 bis 80 in
den mittelgebirgen sogar von über 100
kilometer pro stunde da werden bäume
umstürzen und auch erste abreißen denn
die bäume sind ja noch voller laub heute
nacht zieht die warmfront hier ostwärts
ab danach wird das erst mal ruhig und
die temperaturen sinken auf 15 bis 4
grad morgen wird es sehr mild mit
höchstwerten von 17 bis 23 grad und erst
mal wechseln sonne und wolken
miteinander ab aber schon bald ziehen
von westen diese dicken regenwolken
heran es gibt kräftige schauer und
gewitter und auch schon die ersten
sturmböen in der nacht zu donnerstag
zieht das sturmtief dann weiter ostwärts
und verlässt uns am donnerstag in
richtung nordosten danach wird es
markant kelter statt der 17 bis 23 grad
morgen gibt es am samstag nur noch 7 bis
13 grad guten abend